Jamie just described to us how much does
this put to rest this settlement the
claims against VW on the diesel
emissions not much at all I mean and in
terms of the details I think you know it
to the extent it helps to set aside any
risk you know for investors that this is
going to really blow up that there at
total loggerheads with the regulators
and it's going to turn into a nasty
lawsuit but for consumers if you own one
of these almost 600,000 non-compliant
vehicles in the US and you thought okay
today finally seven months after this
all came out i'm going to know what I
can do with my car right you're just
gonna have to wait two more months at
least so he said in no date of June
twenty-first for them to come back and
try to have a final settlement by then
they're going to have another meeting in
the meantime but they don't have fixes
worked out they don't know what money
people are going to get but the judge
but the judge said we're making good
progress so nine months after it all
comes two comes out then maybe we'll
know what's going to happen Jamie VW set
aside 6.7 billion we have carried this
story all day that the deal struck today
was for 10 billion there's been all
sorts of theoretical figures for what
the total cost could be the VW some
ranging as high as forty two billion
dollars are we any clearer on that we're
not since you know the report of last
night I think you know the 10 billion
lines up somewhat with that original
seven but of course that original you
know seven ish billion 7.3 billion
dollars I think and then after the
currency translation you know that was
originally set aside as a global number
four fixes so if it's going to cost them
ten billion dollars just to fix those in
the US obviously it's more than they did
initially expected of VW has said all
along there pretty quickly said they
knew that it would require more but the
other the other costs whether there are
be criminal penalties from the Justice
Department the shareholder lawsuits in
Europe you know that's still going to be
hanging out there even after we get the
california thing settled which again we
don't know what that's going to cost
even the ten billion that our source
said
for the repairs there's also another big
chunk that's going to probably going to
come out of this California case which
is the remediation that's another's you
know the the funds to undo the damage
that they've done to the environment
okay Jamie before we go just good but
what else is out there what are the
other claims that are out there yeah I
can ran through those but yeah I think
you know the there is a there's a
shareholder lawsuit in Europe there are
still some some claims in Europe there's
the big invest you know the big
investigation by the Justice Department
they're doing a two-track investigation
kind of like they did with BP where
there in this civil case that's in
California along with a lot of customers
and dealers and all that but they're
also running a criminal prosecution that
is technically separate and allows them
to go after after more from there and
then there's of course the cost of
remediation which is going to be
billions it's whether it's a few
billions or several billion